es uno de los sitios más emblemáticos de
tokio el templo budista de asakusa son
organizados muchos reportajes o
grabaciones allí
queremos obtener una autorización de
rodaje en la oficina de prensa del
templo
no aceptan solicitudes y archivos de
rodaje por correo electrónico solo
aceptan por fax o en persona mucho
papeleo en japon muchos formatos para
rellenar somos muy administrativos
administrativa
y sea nori es nuestro tramitador y
traductor un esclavo del fax para
preparar los rodajes tienen que enviar
documentos casi a diario el director del
sitio recibe unos 15 al día y para ella
es muy práctico
recibo muchas llamadas telefónicas así
que tiendo a olvidarme de revisar mi
buzón así al contrario cuando un fax
sale de esta máquina atrae mi atención
pero de qué se trata de inmediato en
japón hay mucha gente mayor que no puede
manejar las computadoras hola se
encuentra demasiado nuevas así que para
ellos el fax es lo más fácil
ya saben el reino de la alta tecnología
de los trenes de alta velocidad aquí
está la otra faceta de japón un país
apegado al papel el nuevo gobierno
quiere poner fin a estos usos poco
ecológicos acaba de lanzar una guerra
contra los faxes y los sellos
administrativos los famosos bancos
se utilizan en todas partes en japón
para firmar documentos en las empresas
cuando se recibe un paquete incluso en
los restaurantes en las facturas cada
ciudadano tiene uno o más ellos a su
nombre o el de su empleador esta
japonesa está buscando uno para la
empresa que acaba de crear estos son los
emblemas de las empresas
5 uso alejando cuando voy al banco y
alaina al día para pagar mis cuentas
para todo lo que tenga que ver con el
dinero que diría que lo uso para toda
apertura si no pones un sello en las
facturas no serán aceptadas así es cómo
eran las empresas japonesas y eso no va
a cargar arrancara conozco a este hombre
hace hancco a mano desde hace casi 70
años esta práctica se importó de china
hace dos milenios este sello de tinta
roja mucho más difícil de falsificar que
una firma manuscrita o digital garantiza
la autenticidad de un documento en el
siglo octavo los japoneses culpables de
fabricar falsos hank o imperiales eran
condenados a la pena de muerte para este
taller familiar la actual
contra los sellos es una negación de la
identidad cultural y política de japón
el banco es una forma de comprometerse
con la verdad en una decisión y de
afirmar realmente las responsabilidades
de uno y ahora los políticos podrán
decir yo no dije eso no hice ese
compromiso el banco era muy importante
para prevenir esos abusos estamos
avanzando hacia una simplificación de
los comportamientos y la era de la
mentira mientras que janko es
precisamente la prueba de que uno no
miente pero hoy en día el banco ya no es
popular en el momento más crítico de la
pandemia los empleados no tenían otra
opción que ir a sus oficinas a firmar
físicamente los documentos fue un freno
al teletrabajo que empujó a las
autoridades a querer deshacerse de él el
fabricante histórico de janco lo
entendió y desarrolló un sello
electrónico entre marzo y junio a cerca
de 300.000 compañías japonesas compraron
su producto focalizan y conectamos con
nuestro servicio uno ya no tiene que ir
al lugar de trabajo y puede autenticar
documentos en línea a través de una
aplicación para compartir documentos
pues gastará está claro que parte de la
cultura japonesa desaparecerá
[Música]
desafortunadamente estamos en el proceso
de pasar del papel a lo digital
pero nunca va a desaparecer del todo la
gente va a seguir usando el hand co
físico con este sistema habrá varias
opciones
y manejando turismo noga miniatura de un
casting con la crisis actual es también
una oportunidad para que japón acelerar
reformas discutidas desde hace tiempo
pero en uno de los países que envejece
más rápidamente en el mundo con un
cuarto de la población mayor de 65 años
todavía les queda algún futuro a estos
implementos de otra época